chef's and Balkan holes monument -
Rashaad vogner was unveiled in leipzig
exactly 200 years after the composer was
born the sculptor had to pay tribute to
the controversial musician without
casting him as a hero
his young Wagner is slightly taller than
the composer was in real life he stands
on the Art Nouveau pedestal designed a
century ago by the artist max klinger
it's an unusual thing to finish
something that someone else started
that's rare and I hope that the work
harmonizes with what's there rather than
being provocative it's a vogner clinger
Balkan hole Monument
it went down well with the onlookers
it's important that the monument should
not be about adulation it should reveal
the controversy that he was a difficult
person who was worthy of some
consideration the shadow in the
background
everybody casts a shadow and his shadow
will remain I think it's great chef and
Vulcan Hall put the final touches on the
bronze sculpture in his studio in
Karlsruhe taking on the job was a brave
task vogner is revered as a musical
genius but also scorned for his
anti-semitic writings that later made
him one of the Nazis favorite composers
reported assaults clamminess Kadam
didn't I deliberately wanted to ignore
this this was about the composer about
the musical artists I didn't want to
trivialize his anti-semitic pamphlets
but this political correctness has to
end somewhere we have to stop seeing his
work in this light stay on the bargain
hall chose to depict a young yet to be
famous Richard Wagner before he left his
native Livesy
he took his inspiration from a design
max klinger made for a four meter tall
monument to the composer in 1913 the
shadow the silhouette is influenced by
max cleaners original design this is
pretty much what it would have looked
like and it's also the size that max
klinger was intending it was supposed to
be a rather large sculpture deep marking
up for hotdogeteria
Balkan hole achieved international
acclaim with his polychromatic wooden
figures he's also painted this bronze
sculpture he lends his figures a sense
of the everyday focusing on their
existential awareness he spent a long
time ensuring he got vogner's expression
just right this is a business
competitive casting in bronze is a bit
more complicated than working in wood
this sculpture was first modeled out of
clay then it went to the foundry where
other hands worked on it and then and
then it came back to me and I've had to
make it mine again naturally painting
the sculpture was part of that process
the fitnah tourists and authors to the
mall on Balkan Ho's monument to vogner
is a figure with an individual
expression unlike his previous works
which are anonymous and mysterious they
could be anybody Balkan Hall has been
honing his craft for some 30 years
sometimes his figures are small-scale
sometimes larger than life like this
2009 sculpture called balancing act a
commentary on the Berlin Wall and how
East Germans coped with their lives
behind it
a professor of sculpture at the Arts
Academy in Karlsruhe Balkan Hall turns
out about a hundred sculptures a year
most are made of wood from the African
wha-wha tree his sculptures are roughly
hewn and can appear unfinished with
traces of the process clearly visible he
leaves it up to the viewers imagination
to complete the image chef and Balkan
hall calls the sculptures unveiling a
historic moment in his life it's also a
milestone for the city of Leipzig at
last it has its own monument to reach
our Vagner